he's probably going to get a pretty bad
Uber rating
now
[Music]
thatan you guys have seen these things
right squirrel suit o squirrel suits
I've always want to try hey don't you
have friends that did this I have a
couple friends don't you have to have X
amount of skydives Millions ofs before
you can so like you have to be so first
when you go skydiving it's tandem right
like with your instructor you have to do
I don't know how many jumps a few before
you start doing on your own right then
you have to do a bunch before you even
get into squirrel suits because like
when you're skydiving you have couple
minutes to make decisions if in case
[__] happens squirrel suits it's less
than a minute it's like 30 seconds 20
seconds so you have to be expert at
making decisions dude that must be an
exhilarating feel dud I seen people die
on
videos why would you look that up I
didn't it just popped up on my feet my
friends that do it they say literally
every year they know one of their
friends is going they just they're just
they and even if they go on a trip like
let's say they all go to like wild Utah
together and they're going to jump from
this rock or whatever they when they all
say like bye to their wives they all
know maybe one of them is not coming
back but they also have to like they
this this is their purpose for
living what the [__] that shit's so
dangerous though do you think sometimes
their wives are like why couldn't they
just been into
Legos that was the purpose for living
why could you be into d or
something because don't they also do
like hardcore military [__] A lot of
them are prior military that crazy [__]
so it's like the funny thing is like
their job can get them killed but also
their Hobbies can get them killed it's
like maybe that's just how it is like at
that point in life when you've already
done this [__] thing like everything
else feels like this well you should be
like a Samurai and do bonsai trees cuz
that's the balance ah balance bonsai
tree is the balance to you're killing
all day no oh like trim a bonsai tree
grow a
bonsai no not like that need just
scissors the balance of like scors if
your life is about murder all day then
you need to create life and you need to
tend to something Del balance balance
yeah like learn how to do sensual
massage if you're out there beating
people up all day yeah dude just learn
how to do Nuru Massage yeah Nur Nuru
that's
easy what you mean bro I got that
unlocked I got the tarps at the house if
they if guys do that uh hell yeah we do
I don't want to imagine that two girls
right yeah that's kind of funny I mean I
could start it up who that this
Daredevil skydiver Nuru Massage
Daredevil was tragically decapitated
holy [__] by the plane wing of the plane
he just jumped out of no [__] way how
did that happen oh hell no so he jumped
out of the
plane and it's did he jump out that way
so the plane hit maybe you're supposed
to jump out that way so the plane go
like these wait what I thought he would
be lower right how did the plane or was
he trying to do tricks do you know cuzz
a lot of those guys they like the reason
why they even get there they push the
boundaries so sometimes they want to do
tricks oh yeah you mean where people
like those guys would go into another
plane by Just Landing next to it or they
like they want to see how close they can
get to the trees or some people they'll
purposely jump out [__] up and they'll
pull the shoot at the last second like
they it's that personality type that
gets into this stuff so even when
they're doing this stuff they're still
pushing yeah they're always pushing so
we have some info here I thought about
to say a video this guy's no we ain't
watching that this guy Nicholas gley was
one of 10 parachutists who were inside
this aircraft uh The 40-Year-Old and
another person leapt out of the plane at
14,000 ft above France dressed in Wing
suits seconds after they were free
falling and enjoying their jump the
pilot operating the plane Allen C made a
fatal decision the pilot so he wanted to
be like oh I want to loop the loop too
and was he doing one of those today's
the air show and then he caught the guy
almost but no okay he thought the two
Wings suit divers were in the clear and
started his rapid descent due to them
wearing the specially designed suit that
allows him to glide through the air
rather than just fall they were actually
parallel with the plane this caused G or
gayy to be decapitated by the aircraft's
wing and he was killed
instantly oh please don't let his
emergency parachute was ejected and he
slowly fell to the ground headless you
think that would have been his answer if
we told asked him that yeah like what's
your like how old would you want to die
and how old and how how yeah he did not
been he probably knew he's probably
going to get a pretty bad Uber rating
now
thatan three and a half stars who the
[__] is this and then you read it like
the citato my friend but like great
conversation with a Sho profile picture
on time [__] Uber clean plane that's
crazy what do you guys what do you guys
think is the most Daredevil them that
you you would want to do like what my
limit is yeah I already do my limits
yeah bro what's your limit I climb free
climb I
surfes I mount well I haven't Mountain
biked in two years but I did but I feel
like it's all acceptable levels where
people go oh that sounds dangerous and
I'm all like it's not that
dangerous but there's people like more
people doing dangerous [__] that's why
you're just like it's not that dangerous
seriously but to normal people they're
like ooh that sounds daring you know I I
drive without my seat belt sometimes
that's just dangerous I think dirt
biking over the jumps like this big
jumps oh [__]
that's have you done that
before no I haven't
I I think I think you already stunt on
the freeway dude that [__] look that's
dangerous that's real dangerous [__] for
me I'm doing control things yeah bro
you're a gangster yeah I think I would
have done skydiving before but then
after having a kid like I was already
like a [__] and then now I'm like even
more of a [__] it's okay though you've
never skydived I've never skydived
before I wanted to I want to too
Colleen's calling you a [__] in her
head no j JK Adventure cuz I've also
never done it but I know it's on my
bucket list like I have to it's been on
my bucket list until I had a kid and I
was like oh I don't know just they say
the stats are like you have a better
chance at dying on the drive to go
skydiving than you do actually skydiving
true so that means we got two chances of
death that's right cuz I know people
that have thousands of jumps yeah I mean
the guy that I went with it's like
getting a cup of coffee he was like i'
this is like my
9,357 jump I'm like crazy but then
there's that one day where he forgets
the parachute just like every guy
forgets the keys or his wallet yeah fun
wallet I want a ear I want a new new
diver a new diver would just be more
like everything is good cuz I checked
everything but then a guy that's done
over 10,000 goes I got this dude there's
a story of a dude who's recording his
homies jumping out the plane oh and he
forgot to put on his he forgot to put on
his shoe cuz he was so excited so he
just jumped
together and they're like yeah you
[__] oh [__] no shoot did someone save
them did they all come come and get I
don't think they realized cuz they're
just focused on filming oh and they
couldn't communicate they look to the
side to the bra went down oh my God he
was more busy on I bet you he was like
this time I'm not going to forget the
memory card in my camera he's like I got
everything ready and then he jumps and
he goes but the but the shoot I forgot
to shoot can you imagine that moment of
realization
ho [__] I've been doing that I feel like
that's such a guy thing to do like we're
just [__] all right dude I always
forget my phone today I will not forget
my phone and then you put it in your
pocket you forget your shoes when you
leave C or your keys or something it's
like your brain only has one thing to
remember but it throws away the other
thing that it was remembering has to
replace I'm not like that at all that's
why guys need women in their Liv that's
why women are more responsible are
always good at that I know exactly where
everything is at all the time I've had
to get my [__] workout bag like air
shipped over here because I [__] I
was like perfect I knew everything I
needed in my
luggage I'm like oh [__] I got to film a
workout video have any of my [__] hey
Gio for some reason someone forgot to
pack the
workout that someone I don't know what
except your key that was a out of
character moment that but then I found
it because you know I don't ever
misplace things for too long but that
was a I think dudes can only think about
one thing at a time that wasn't like
that was a that was a freak accent that
wasn't like I'm going somewhere and then
I go where's my left shoe and then guys
do that [__] all the time where you just
[__] constantly forget lose [__]
whatever or you go to a store to get
something you're like I need to go get
some butter so you go to the [__]
store you leave with a bag of apples a
watermelon some grape and some cheese
and you get home and you're like [__] I
forgot the butter do you feel like it's
cuz certain guys when they do things
like that they're just always in a hurry
I think our main focus isn't that our
main focus is what I what what do I have
to do today what's the main purpose
today yeah that's it I think guys only
think one thing I time like that yeah
cuz I'm probably troubleshooting like
all right this Deal's coming up what's
the best way to negotiate these terms
whatever right and you're like driving
to the store and you're like all right I
got to go get butter and you're like
yeah all right oh you know what this
will be a good idea if I give him these
things he might say yes whatever
whatever damn man watermelon on sale I
haven't had watermelon in a minute and
then you go get your St and then like
you might be talking to your friends and
your friend might be like oh bro have
you had these and I'm like what man
these chips you got to try them and I'm
like oh you know I'm going to try it you
know I'm going to try it it just keeps
climbing
I'm the opposite I'm looking at my
fridge and I know exactly what I'm
missing I make a list and I [__] go
and I get exactly what I need nerd n
lame you know like so like I'm in charge
of um both me and Joe are in charge of
Tao seizure medicine so he has to take
it right sh so when it's just me because
I know I'm a [__] dude and I can't
[__] this [__] up when my alarm goes off
I have a no hesitation rule I go and I
pour out his seizure medication I pour
it and I just go like like this and if
anyone talks me shut up shut up shut up
shut up I know I can't be interrupted
because I know this is something that is
important and then I go drink it and
then I can get distracted to do whatever
but I feel like that's a guy but ADHD
thing too like we can't be distracted if
someone goes ding dong and then like I
go oh oh you're selling solar panels oh
very cool I'mma [__] forget this [__]
[__] T could be [__] season away
I'm like no what the [__] you're telling
me I'm going to save how much every year
a I feel like women are more like detail
oriented but in like vast majority yeah
I can't put it down I'm like I'm holding
this like it's a [__] million dollar
diamond ring and I'm just holding it but
I think we're really good at survival
and like tactical and like aware of
things though detail wise I think also
we we're good at tunnel vision and to
stick obsessively with something until
it's fixed so like I would say like the
the mind of a guy is like you're
breaking down opening up this engine all
this stuff right and then the girl with
a nice body stops by and you just go
what the [__] and you're like oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God and then
you go back to the engine is like being
taken apart whatever whatever whatever
all this stuff and then you forget to
shower it's been s days God damn right
no no that's when I would have been like
yo you smell like onion my boy my boy
you got to put that [__]
on
[Music]